Hey Nina, what’s up?
Hey Tom, I’m working on a piece about
all the Spider-Man movies before
“No Way Home” and I could use a little recap.
Well, that might be hard. We’re on
our eighth movie and third reboot
in two decades. There’s a lot of ground to cover.
That’s alright. Just start from the beginning.
Pretend you’re explaining Spider-Man
to a woman who couldn’t care less.
Wow, it’s like this is what I’ve been
training for my entire life! Alright,
so depending on which franchise you’re
watching, Peter Parker is a nerdy high
school student who’s either 19,
28, or two weeks from retirement.
(sigh) Uh huh.
And he either gets bitten by a
genetically engineered spider,
covered in a bunch of genetically engineered
spiders, or the movie assumes that you saw
the first five origin stories and
skips all that crap. In any case,
he finds himself quite suddenly able to
do all of the things that a spider do.
Can I get a few examples?
Well, he can stick to things. He can shoot
things that stick to things. And of course,
he can use the sticky things that he
shoots to stick things to other things.
So Marvel’s most popular superhero is a
teenage boy whose hands are just always sticky?
Yeah, you get it.
Cool okay. Just
making sure that I’m keeping
up. So, this… Spider-Man?
Yes, Spider-Man.
Does… whatever a spider can?
That’s correct.
Is he strong?
Hey, listen, bud. He’s got radioactive blood.
...So no?
No, he’s very sick.
Got it. Go on.
Thanks to his newfound stickiness, Peter
Parker is instilled with a new sense of
self confidence and starts to go down the wrong
path, either with Tobey Maguire participating
in bloodsport and homophobia or Andrew
Garfield playing basketball too mean.
Uh huh.
Luckily, he has his Uncle Ben there
to guide his way. Tobey Maguire’s
Uncle Ben teaches him that with great power,
there must also come great responsibility.
Well that’s succinct and easy to rememb...
If you think that’s great, just wait, because
Andrew Garfield’s Uncle Ben says something
equally iconic. Hold on a second, I’ll look
it up. (typing) Right, according to this,
Andrew Garfield’s Uncle Ben says that if you
spider can do good things for other people,
you have a moral obligation to do those things,
and Tom Holland Peter Parker drops another zippy
morality banger when he tells Tony Stark that
when you can do the things that he spider can,
but you don’t, and then bad things
happen, they happen because of spider you.
Wow, the t-shirts just write themselves.
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man fights a guy who’s mad
about work and a guy who’s mad about science.
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man fights a guy who’s
mad about science and a guy who’s mad about work.
Both Spider-Men wait until the last movie
in their franchise to drastically overcrowd
things to the point where the story
is practically unbearable. It's great.
So, what about Tom Holland Spider-Man?
Totally different. When they brought
him into the MCU, it was kind of a
fresh start for the character, so
they decided to try something new.
So he fights a guy who’s mad about work
and then a guy who’s mad about science.
So does he wait until his very last movie to
overcrowd everything until the
story is totally unbearable?
No.
No?
Probably not.
Terrific. Let’s talk romance. Is
there a Mrs. Spider-Man on the scene?
You’d better believe it,
sister. Tobey Maguire Spider-Man is
in love with Kirsten Dunst Mary Jane.
Okay, great, what happens with them?
Peter breaks up her marriage and then
goes to her work and punches her.
Neat! Andrew Garfield?
He was going to have a Mary Jane,
but they cut her out of the movie
to make room for stuff like subway token
mysteries and Paul Giamatti. So instead,
he dates Gwen Stacy, up until he, you
know, breaks her neck and kills her.
...Tom Holland?
He beats up his first girlfriend’s
dad so bad that she has to move,
and then in the next movie
he hooks up with Zendaya.
But like, she’s probably going to be fine, right?
She’ll probably be fine! We should in no way read
too much into the fact that by this
point in their respective franchises,
both of the other Spider-Men had been to like four
funerals and Tom Holland has only been to one.
(clears throat)
She’s probably going to be fine! And No Way
Home is not going to be another in a series
of overstuffed final entries
in a Spider-Man saga, right?
No.
No!
No?
No. No. No. ...Nina? Nina? Are you still there?
I didn’t even tell you about Peter’s Aunt May.
She keeps Benjamin Buttoning between movies. Nina.
They’re getting Millie Bobby Brown
to play her in the next one. Nina.